some absolutely unbelievable deposition
transcripts have been published and they
relate to very dangerous fruit it
appears as though
you know donald trump remember when he
kept talking about the oranges of an
investigation take a look at the oranges
of the investigation it looks as though
that may not have been just a verbal
glitch he might actually have some kind
of an irrational fear of fruit we have
testimony from uh when donald trump gave
a videotape deposition in october
related to a lawsuit filed by some
protesters
against the former president's security
staff who were being accused of assault
and trump gave videotape deposition and
the topic of dangerous fruit
apparently
almost an obsession for trump we're
gonna look at a little bit of the
deposition transcript here
um trump was asked
okay and you said that if you see
someone getting ready to throw a tomato
just knock the crap out of them would
you that was your statement and trump
said oh yeah it was very dangerous and
trump was asked what was very dangerous
and he said we were threatened
with what trump says they were going to
throw fruit we were threatened we had a
threat
trump was asked how did you become aware
that there was a threat that people were
going to throw fruit
and trump said we were told i thought
secret service was involved in that
actually but we were told and you get
hit with fruit it's now it's very
violent stuff we were on alert for that
the questioner says a tomato is a fruit
after all i guess
and
and trump says and you know what
and then
mr mr goldman says it has seeds
to which trump says it's worse than
tomato it's other things also but tomato
when they start doing that stuff
it's very dangerous
there was an alert out that day
trump was asked who were you speaking to
when you said and trump says the
audience
and the question then is so you were
speaking to the audience when you said
if they saw someone getting ready to
throw a tomato just knock the crap out
of them would you
and trump said that was to the audience
it was said sort of in jess but maybe
you know a little truth it's very
dangerous stuff
you can get killed with those things
the questioner says so were you trying
to incentivize people to engage in
violence trump's lawyer objects and then
trump says no i wanted to have people be
ready because we were put on alert that
they were going to do fruit
and some fruit is a lot worse than
tomatoes are bad by the way but it's
very dangerous very very dangerous
now i do want to say it is absolutely
true that a tomato is a fruit fruit is
the sweet and fleshy product of a tree
or plant that can sane contains seeds
and can be eaten eaten as food
and
when you talk about a tomato
the fruit grows from the flower of the
tomato plant and thus tomatoes are
indeed fruits i would make the case
that the most dangerous fruit would
technically be a pumpkin a pumpkin both
is a fruit which a lot of people don't
know but it is
and the record heaviest fruit in the
world was a 2600 pound pumpkin that
could easily kill someone i mean that's
like dropping a small car on someone the
the trick would be of course picking it
up and how you pick it up i don't know
guys this is crazy
fruit they were put on notice about
fruit and it reminds me of the great
film mrs doubtfire of course with the
late robin williams the infamous scene
of the run by fruiting where a mrs
doubtfire throws a lime at the back of
the head of appears brosnan's character
and there's also for film buffs out
there there is a very famous continuity
error in that scene where robin williams
character as mrs doubtfire takes a lime
and throws it
and then when the cut goes back to robin
williams that very lime that he slash
she threw is back on the pile of limes
this is a true film buff thing for those
who care about this type of trivia but
very strange a very bizarre obsession on
the dangers of
fruit uh
there it is and maybe this relates to
trump
and flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
somehow if it says anything about his
diet i don't know
if you're looking for a therapist or
seeking treatment for mental health or
substance abuse check out compassionate
care compassionate care is a medical
practice offering mental health
treatment that's affordable
and remote
in the comfort of your home
compassionate care offers remote talk
therapy to patients nationwide you can
establish a meaningful long-term
relationship without having to drive to
an office for every appointment
psychiatry services are available
remotely to patients in pennsylvania and
new york compassionate care offers
medication assisted treatment for opioid
or alcohol addiction with the
medications buprenorphine and naltrexone
available in pennsylvania new york and
delaware compassionate care does not
require insurance they're a small
independent practice they support the
david pakman show and you can support
them and they're ready to talk to you
get a free consultation by calling 855
208
2408 or go to
caredrs.com
the link is down below